[Music]
for hundreds of years
European kings and princes were absolute
rulers in their castles overlooking the
cities and towns from on high then came
democracy and the rule of the people but
in least in Stein things are a bit
different even to this day as Prince
Alois of least in stein explains for the
first year even if the prince lives in a
castle 100 metres above the valley he's
got a very close natural and informal
relationship with the people the
hereditary Prince is an expert on law
and economics and a member of Europe's
wealthiest noble family but he describes
himself as simply the first servant of
his country muncom the people can pass a
vote of no confidence in the monarch in
a referendum the people can even abolish
the monarchy in a referendum so just
like an elected politician the monarch
always has to consider the interests of
the people if not in the long run he'll
run into problems and probably an be
comped that may be true but least in
steins Prince also holds a unique right
to veto any law passed in Parliament if
he wishes he can also dismiss the
government and appoint judges these
powers are a bone of contention for the
monarchies few critics at home
mentioned in the race around asparagus
when it comes to the citizens judicial
rights election Steiners like to say
they'd rather leave it up to the people
but the castle does they'll take care of
it that's also a form of pragmatism and
division of tasks but a ticket
undermines democracy with a shot at the
Democrat II but leashed and Stein's
economy is booming and unemployment is
virtually non-existent the
principality's financial dealings have
made it rich and it is home to numerous
banks financial advisors and trustees in
2008 one of the princess bank employees
sold foreign tax inspectors confidential
documents they involved thousands of
accounts held by tax dodgers and
contained billions of euros and
undeclared funds well let's go chef hmm
he blew the Liechtenstein system
sky-high with the data he took from the
Royal trust that's an achievement so
thank you hook these is love I think he
changed this country more than any
artist or intellectual or Prince ever
did before
oh you do feel da GU shaft that the
people at least in Stein and the prince
were called robber barons but they came
through the scandal United following
international pressure the financial
sector was reformed to adhere to
European transparency rules Lincoln
County are looking back it's very clear
that this was the right an important
decision to make at the time as well
we're estimating that for the end of
2018 we'll be managing over 300 billion
Swiss francs in assets and provided
information protecting p.m. which is
also a source of income for the Legion
Steiners so they took the tax haven
affair as a minor faux pas on the
princess part so they're part of us
they're us and we are they didn't have
its principal still be a farming village
today they're a very likable family
we're looking forward to their big
jubblies those who just could all see
you believe the people down in the
valley are full of praise and up at the
castle hereditary Prince Alois is well
aware of his high up
ratings surrounded incidentally by one
of Europe's biggest private art
collections this is by Rubens one of his
few landscapes intervening long shaft
netsuke of male find the sights feebly
on the underside tended to concentrate
more and biblical as well as antique
motifs always with powerful figures 15
figure 1 Cynthia leashed inch 9 - seems
to like powerful figures and in 2019 and
this age of democracy the small state
and its powerful princely family
celebrates their 300th anniversary
[Music]